das ist wirklich kaum zu glauben schon
am dritten tag seines praktikums bei der
nasa hat der 17-jährige wolski einen
bislang unbekannten planeten entdeckt
1338 b ist siebenmal so groß wie die
erde und etwa 1300 lichtjahre von uns
entfernt und der neu entdeckte planet
hat eine weitere super spannende
eigenschaft die ihn ganz besonders macht
sich zum science fiction hier gibt es
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
die nasa hatte dem 17-jährigen wolf
kukla die aufgabe gegeben
die unterschiedliche helligkeit von
sternen aufzuzeichnen dazu schaute sich
der schüler praktika die aufnahmen des
nasa-satelliten test genauer an dieser
trend setting exoplanet service
satellite ist ein weltraumteleskop der
nasa und wird für die suche nach
exoplaneten eingesetzt die sich in einer
distanz von bis zu 300 lichtjahren
befinden der start der mission fand im
april 2018 mit einer falcon 9 statt
bereits am dritten tag seines praktikums
fand wolf etwas verdächtiges bei seiner
analyse und zwar hatte sich ein dunkler
fleck vor die sonne geschoben die ja
gerade im visier hatte dazu wolf zuerst
dachte ich es wäre eine sternen
finsternis aber der zeitpunkt passte
nicht es stellte sich heraus dass es ein
planet ist und tatsächlich war es nicht
einfach irgendein planet den der nasa
praktikant somit überraschenderweise
aufgespürt hatte sondern ein ganz
besonderer denn der planet kreist um
zwei sonnen dazu wolf es ist so wie
luchs heimatplaneten turin in star wars
doch auch für die nasa fachleute war
diese entdeckung eine ganz besondere
überraschung und zudem auch noch eine
premiere denn zuvor hat es noch nie
einen planeten in einer umlaufbahn von
zwei sternen aufgespürt in der
fachsprache ist von einem sogenannten
binären planet die rede
die genauen analysen ergaben dass der
planet sieben mal so groß ist wie die
erde und etwa 1300 lichtjahre von uns
entfernt liegt konkret befindet er sich
im sternbild viktor seine beiden sterne
umkreisen einander alle 15 tage nach
angaben der nasa hat der eine von ihnen
eine masse die etwa zehn prozent größer
ist als die unserer sonne der andere
stern soll nicht nur kühler und weniger
hell sein sondern auch
ein drittel der sonnenmasse haben sie
eine genaue bezeichnung lautet jetzt tue
oder ti 1338 b denn alle planeten die
textausschnitte bekommen keinen namen
sondern ein code der sich aus buchstaben
und zahlen zusammensetzt das praktikum
von wolf fand schon im sommer 2009 10
statt doch seine spektakuläre entdeckung
wurde es in diesen tagen auf einer
konferenz der astronomie christi in
honolulu veröffentlicht die nasa hat
diese entdeckung auch in einem papier
festgehalten und dieses bei einem
fachmagazin zur veröffentlichung
eingereicht der 17-jährige
schülerpraktikant wird hier als co autor
genannt mit hilfe von tests hatte ein
nasa forschungsteam erst in diesen tagen
einen anderen planeten entdeckt und zwar
den exoplaneten 700 de dieser ist wohl
so groß wie die erde und nur rund 100
lichtjahre von uns entfernt
laut nasa könnten die bedingungen hier
tatsächlich genau richtig sein um
flüssiges wasser auf der oberfläche zu
ermöglichen
auch hier bekamen die fachleute support
von hobby astronomie teams den test
hatte den stern den tui 700 dem umkreis
zuerst falsch eingestuft und das hatte
auswirkungen auf dessen drei planeten
die somit zunächst für größer und heißer
gehalten wurden hat sie wirklich sind
dieser fehler wurde unter anderem von
einem schüler mit dem namen elton
spencer aufgedeckt gliese 581 g leben
auf exoplanet zu 100 anklicken anschauen
und us comics tv unbedingt abonnieren
sehr cooler kanal bis dann bleibt dran